oui françois c'est le coroner à
l'appareil j'ai besoin de toi vous on a
retrouvé notre est à l'honneur mort dans
des conditions suspectes
je vais devoir mener leur enquête est ce
que tu peux prendre le relais sur la
colorisation du prochain épisode
oui mais non non non enfin moi je suis
pas est à l'honneur medios et plus à
terre ils perdent en route on truque
enfin moi je suis juste vis des as n'est
pas moyen non non non non non non j'ai
une totale confiance en toi je suis sûr
que tu vas t'en sortir les fichiers sont
non pas beau être belle mais non non non
c'est juste pas possible c'est trop
dangereux pour moi 31-19 nord et
n'oublie pas on peut rater sa vie mais
pas sa marque a
et merde
[Musique]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mme encore je
suis ravi de vous retrouver dans ces
conditions un petit peu particulière
vous savez pourquoi
voilà on va pas s'arrêter pour autant de
faire des vidéos je suis fait une petite
pause pour accuse un peu le coup quand
même mais là c'est reparti et on est
reparti sur du très très lourd mais du
très très très très lourd et cette vidéo
ça me fait super plaisir de la faire
d'ailleurs si vous êtes nouveau ici vous
intéressez un petit peu à la vidéo au
tournage aux caméras au montage tout ça
mais vous pouvez envisager
éventuellement 2 vous abonner si ça vous
plaît il ya plein de choses qui je pense
vous intéresseront beaucoup sur cette
chaîne puis la cloche tout ça tout ça
pour être notifiée voilà ça c'est dit ça
c'est fait maintenant on y va alors là
quelques temps mike et fabio de la
chaîne chronique fiction sont venus
discuter avec moi et juste j'étais comme
un gosse quand ils ont commencé à
discuter avec moi parce que j'adore
leurs chaînes vraiment si vous la
connaissez pas aller la voir c'est une
chaîne qui traite de cinéma et puis plus
particulièrement des morts au cinéma et
c'est juste excellent en termes de
profondeur analyse de films vraiment moi
j'adore cette chaîne et sur cette chaîne
ya aussi un personnage principal qui
présente un petit peu tout ça le coroner
qui est un personnage assez
extraordinaire je trouve qu'ils joué par
stéphane godin voilà stéphane godin qui
est la voie du robot accueille sedan
interstellar qui est mon film préféré
donc ça veut dire que grosso modo dans
cette vidéo j'ai la voix comme vous avez
pu voir à l'intro d'un mec qui a joué
parce que moi je pense que c'est joué
aussi doublé dans mon film préféré
voilà les chipmunks unlocked donc bien
entendu un après avoir vu cette vidéo
vous allez voir dans la description il
ya le lien vers la chaîne et vous allez
voir ses vidéos c'est extraordinaire
c'est extraordinairement bien filmé
c'est pour ça qu'avec maïté fabio on
s'est donné un petit défi enfin ils
m'ont lancé un petit défi à savoir
reproduire la colo l'étalonnage de leurs
vidéos et là j'ai fait je ne suis pas
est à l'honneur bien évidemment le
terreau neige c'est un métier à part
entière mais j'ai trouvé très
intéressant de vous parler de ça et
d'étalonner justement leurs fichiers
parce qu'il ya des choses que vous avez
potentiellement pouvoir rencontrer des
éléments qui vont peut-être vous aider
aussi dans final cut des outils que vous
connaissez peut-être pas pour étalonner
plus facilement et de façon plus précise
donc on va en parler tout de suite c'est
parti on y va alors la première chose à
savoir
ces fichiers là et c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles il m'intéresse c'est
qu'ils ont été shootées en log sur une
caméra sony s'en fout un peu le log il y
en a deux plein de sortes et on va en
parler et et à l'orée du log c'est pas
comme est talonné des fichiers sans
profil d'image ou brut
c'est un petit peu plus complexe que ça
mais c'est surtout hyper intéressant le
log grosso modo en brut ça ressemble à
ça est clairement c'est pas beau c'est
c'est tout délavé c'est il ya aucun
contrat sait rien et on pourrait très
bien se dire mais c'est quoi l'intérêt
du coup c'est que déjà le fait d'avoir
ce profil d'image qu'on appelle plat un
flat
ça permet d'avoir une plage dynamique
beaucoup plus grande c'est à dire qu'on
va récupérer
plus d'informations dans les basses
lumières et dans les hautes lumières
grosso modo si vous filmez avec un
profil standard neutre quand c'est noir
c'est noir on dit que c'est bouché on
voudra beau remonter les ombres on
n'aura pas les détails qui se trouvent
dans l'ombre
et quand ces blancs on dit que c'est
cramé que s'est brûlé et on pourra
baisser l'exposition on n'aura pas
d'information à ce niveau là non plus
voilà la plage dynamique c'est ça une
grande plage dynamique c'est une plage
dynamique qui vous permet d'avoir des
informations même si on a un peu
surexposé ou un peu sous exposé son plan
ça permet de rattraper beaucoup de
choses l'autre point intéressant du log
c'est en termes de couleurs du fait
qu'on ait une très faible saturation sur
le profil on va pouvoir récupérer là
aussi pas mal de couleurs et surtout on
va pouvoir en faire un petit peu ce
qu'on veut justement de ces couleurs là
on va pouvoir les modifier si on veut
mais là ça va pas forcément être le
propos de notre vidéo et donc par
définition il ya aussi un inconvénient à
ce blog c'est que ben il faut du post
traitement on peut pas publier du log
tel quel
puisque vous avez vu le rendu est
vraiment pas ouf c'est pas quelque chose
de très joli en soit en brut il va
falloir le post traité il va falloir
faire un étalonnage qu'on va faire ici
dans le final alors avant de commencer
je préfère préciser final cut c'est pas
le meilleur logiciel pour est talonné un
davinci est beaucoup plus puissante
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs chronique fiction était
talonné sur davinci ici on va essayer
surtout de comprendre comment fonctionne
le log et on va essayer de reproduire la
colorimétrie qu'on a dans chroniques
fiction donc maintenant vous êtes
prévenus vous êtes prêt vous êtes tous
on va directement dans final cut
ok donc j'ai placé dans ma timeline ici
les deux plans c'est à dire qu'ici j'ai
le plan brut ici et ici là j'ai le plan
avec la colo fait par l'état l'odeur de
chroniques fiction qui
malencontreusement été on sait pas trop
où on sait pas trop voilà donc ce que
vous pouvez constater ici c'est que ben
on a devant que se profile très flat
très peu saturé très peu contrastée la
première opération ça va être de
recontre as they et de re saturé de ça
il ya deux possibilités
il ya une façon rapide et une façon un
peu moins rapide vous allongez vous
montrer la première chose à faire déjà
c'est d'aller ici dans l'inspecteur est
d'aller dans lutte de caméras alors on
en avait parlé dans la vidéo qui
s'affichent au dessus avec adeline les
luttes
ce sont donc des espèces de filtre on va
dire pour faire très très simples qui
vont nous permettre de se donner un look
mais il ya aussi ce qu'on appelle des
luttes de caméras qui elles vont être
dédiés à changer les espaces
colorimétriques pour faire simple là on
va passer du log oac 709 donc ça va nous
recontre as they et nous re saturé
automatiquement l'image ici donc dans
l'oeil de caméras je vais aller chercher
alors qu'il me semble que c'est dû s log
iii hop voilà et instantanément
on retrouve la couleur on retrouve le
contraste on a quelque chose de plutôt
pas mal alors ça ça peut être bien si on
n'a pas forcément le temps problème
c'est que ça reste quelque chose de figé
on peut pas faire quelque chose de faim
là dessus c'est automatique la lutte on
peut pas la règle est forcément même en
intensité ici on peut pas trop
bidouiller donc ce qu'on va faire nous
plutôt que de faire ça je vais annuler
un petit commandait d'être aux affaires
nous c'est qu'on va faire tout ça
manuellement d'abord on va re contrastée
pour ça je sélectionne mon plan je vais
aller cliquer ici là sur les réglages de
couleurs et sur exposition alors pour
contrat c'est une image c'est très
simple on va baisser les temps sombres
on va pas trop loin à vue si je descends
trop on voit plus rien on va baisser les
tons sombres un petit peu voilà
et on va monter les tons clairs et on va
laisser les temps intermédiaires à peu
près là où ils sont donc là déjà on peut
faire un avant après et c'est plutôt pas
mal
déjà on a quelque chose qui se rapproche
à on est beaucoup moins saturé
on a quelque chose qui se rapproche
maintenant je voudrais voir un petit peu
si en termes d'exposition si je suis bon
ou pas est-ce que je suis sur quelque
chose qui ressemble à l'original ou pas
alors je peux le faire à l'oeil un
comparant ici mais je vais pouvoir
utiliser des outils qui sont en final
cut qui vont être très très très
précieux pour pouvoir savoir si on est
dans le vrai ou pas parce que des fois
on ne sait pas forcément alors pour ça
je vais aller dans présentation et je
vais cliquez sur instruments vidéo voilà
donc ici je peux modifier l'apparence
ici je peux avoir plusieurs éléments ici
gérer ou un seul ici moi j'ai mis ces
deux là j'ai donc cette oscilloscopes
ici qui va expliquer l'exposition voir
comment mon plan est exposé et ici c'est
la même chose mais au niveau des
couleurs et on peut voir assez
facilement si je me mets ici sur mon
plan brut vous voyez que ici on est on
est pas au du tout là en terme
d'exposition et surtout on va pas
jusqu'à 0,1 au niveau des noirs et si ça
va être les tons sombres et plus on va
aller vers le sans plus on va être sur
les tons clairs et l'appareil pour la
saturation on est pas du tout jusqu'en
bas et on n'est pas du tout jusqu'en
haut
c'est typiquement le profil du 6 juillet
sur la version est talonné ici vous
voyez qu'en termes d'exposition les
choses sont très différentes et en
termes de couleurs c'est pareil ça va
beaucoup plus loin on arrive même
jusqu'à sortent donc l'idée ça va être
avec les outils de final cut d'essayer
de faire match est plus ou moins ses
courbes pour avoir un résultat qui se
ressemblent un minimum donc je vais
remettre ici mes réglages d'exposition
et donc je vois que ici je traîne pas
mal entre 50 et 75 alors qu'ici
ça va quand même un petit peu plus haut
donc je vais tout simplement monter
l'exposition générale voilà ici pour
remonter un petit peu là mais je vois
que mes noir d'école un petit peu du
zéro donc on va les remettre les
redescendre voilà surtout n'abusez pas
ça sert à rien d'aller très haut ou très
bas sur les curseurs c'est souvent des
manipulations un petit peu de précisions
alors maintenant qu'on s'est occupé du
contraste on voit qu'on a quelque chose
de beaucoup plus sympa en termes
d'exposition
on va maintenant s'occuper de la couleur
pour cela je vais aller dans saturation
et là je vais augmenter là de manière
générale l'intégralité ici de mon plan
pour retrouver la couleur je vais
regarder un petit peu mon oscilloscopes
et ici on est effectivement sur quelque
chose qui est assez assez similaire
s'est pas encore complètement bon mais
on n'est vraiment pas loin pour aller
encore plus loin et pour pouvoir
vraiment faire le comparatif entre les
deux il ya encore un autre outil je vais
aller dans fenêtre affiché dans l'espace
de travail et visualiseur de comparaison
alors je me suis enregistré mois des des
images ici en fait pour faire le
comparatif donc tout simplement on se
met à un endroit où on vous donne à
notre image de référence et on va
cliquer sur enregistrer l'image pour
ajouter notre image
moi j'ai déjà fait dans mon navigateur
là j'ai plusieurs plans donc ici on va
prendre celui là où on a le coroner ou
alors on va voir un petit peu ce qui a
amélioré potentiellement alors déjà ce
qu'on peut voir c'est que les hautes
lumières à mon avis sont un peu plus
haute dans l'original donc on va aller
monter un peu plus et les basses
lumières un petit peu plus basse voilà
on est sur quelque chose d'un peu plus
proche peut-être on voit augmenter un
petit peu aussi
là les médiums très bien encore baisser
un petit peu les noirs
voilà hockey en termes de couleurs on
est sur quelque chose d'assez proche
peut-être qu'on peut booster un peu plus
la couleur ici en ajoutant un second
réglages couleurs on va pouvoir remonter
encore l'exposition encore un peu plus
donc là voilà on n'est pas trop non plus
parce que sinon ça va être dégueulasse
voilà up ici
on est sur quelque chose qui ressemble
pas mal voilà on est peut-être allé un
brin too much en couleurs on va baisser
un tout petit peu voilà donc là on est
pas mal là où ça pêche c'est ici sur
notre cadavre alors je vais être
complètement transparent avec vous j'ai
testé avant un bien sûr et ça a été
impossible pour moi de dissocier le
teint de peau du cadavre qui est un faux
cadavre de celui du coroner
donc ça veut dire que là effectivement
mon cadavre ici on va mettre là l'image
de référence pour vous puissiez voir mon
cadavre
ici dans la colo de chroniques fiction
il est vachement de désaturer même on
peut voir le sens ici est très désaturer
il est sur un rouge un petit peu cheap
bordeaux un petit peu car main alors que
chez moi il est hyper flashy et et ça et
ça ne fait pas du tout donc ce que j'ai
fait pour faire un petit peu de triche
pour avoir quand même ce plan qui
ressemble un minimum à l'original je
suis allé à me mettre jusqu ici j'ai
fait un cut j'ai fait un cut et j'ai
fait une colle aux différentes sur cette
partie là de sur celle ci et vous allez
voir que même s'il ya un cut la colo
elle va passer comme une lettre à la
poste
donc ici ce qui m'embête c'est la
saturation et c'est surtout la
saturation du säntis il est un peu pâlot
notre cadavre mais il a quand même un
peu de couleurs donc je vais baisser
déjà je vais enlever le deuxième
réglages de saturation je vais aller sur
le premier je vais baisser un petit peu
voilà la couleur pour match et la peau
et je vais aller chercher un réglage qui
s'appelle courbe teinte saturation ici
et je vais utiliser times contre ça tu
ça veut dire qu'en gros sur cette courbe
on va pouvoir les chercher une couleur
et la bc en saturation
donc je vais prendre ma pipe est je vais
aller chercher le sens ici donc le rouge
voyez le mais plutôt dans du orange mais
on va le décaler un petit peu et quand
je baisse hop je baisse la saturation et
voyelles en arrive exactement sur la
même couleur entre les deux donc là on
est pas mal donc si on lance l'image
on est sur quelque chose de pas mal le
problème c'est pas là et du coup c'est
hyper voyant on part sur un changement
de couleur drastiques
donc ce que je vais faire tout
simplement c'est à l'ecal est un fondu
enchaîné entre les deux est comme ça
hop ça va passer vous vous le savez
maintenant vous le voyez forcément vous
voyez l'astuce mais si je vous l'avais
pas dit vous l'auriez probablement pas
vu et ça ça vient de l'outil final cut
qui a ses limites
on a des nuances que on peut pas
forcément retravailler dans le final cut
que je sais pas forcément retravailler
dans davinci on peut être beaucoup plus
précis
n'empêche que là on arrive à un truc
plutôt sympa et voilà on est sur notre
plan qui ressemble quand même comme deux
gouttes d'eau à l'original alors
peut-être ce qu'on va faire
ici j'ai remarqué aussi sur ce plan là
si vous voyez à cet endroit là il ya une
lumière qui est légèrement orangé et ici
elle est quand même un petit peu plus
jaune ici orange et 6 jaunes donc on va
utiliser le même outil de cours de
teinte saturation pour apprendre cette
fois-ci teinte contre teinte ce qui va
permettre de modifier la teinte on va
aller chercher ce jaune qui est là et si
je le monde vous voyez on parla vergio
du rose du viol et du verre là nous on
va juste le temps de terre un peu plus
en orange pour match et pour match et
ici là ici là on est exactement sur la
même teinte ça ça peut être des repères
qui peuvent vous aider pour être sûr qu
en termes de couleurs on soit raccord
avec ce qu'on voulait au départ après là
on a fait quelque chose de très neutre
eux sont restés sur quelque chose
d'assez reste donc très belle lumière un
très bel éclairage un très beau cadre
donc a pas forcément besoin dans le
faire des caisses et de m une lutte de
look ou des choses comme ça on est resté
quelque chose de très neutre mais on va
pouvoir modifier aussi autant qu'on veut
la couleur ici on va pouvoir faire un
petit il est orange si on veut si on
donnait un côté un petit peu cinéma
voilà alors je voulais juste essayer
pour voir et je le fais en direct j'ai
pas essayé avant voir si les luttes que
j'ai fait alors là pour aller mettre une
lutte up a ajouté ça va voir si les
luttes que j'ai fait était grande et
bien voilà donc on va
voir ici ce que ça donne on va mettre la
lutte dont on va quand même être la
lutte de caméras up s log
ok c'est plutôt sympa on va la mettre à
1,75 à c'est plutôt pas mal je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être aussi baisser
un petit peu là les ombres
ah ouais c'est plutôt pas mal je suis
content j'aime bien moi je dis
franchement mike et fabio en moody comme
ça là un petit peu plus un petit peu
d'essence et c'est pas dégueulasse 1 si
ça vous dit un pack de lutte sur your
type saleh de la chaîne tout ça moi je
dis ça je dis rien et voilà les amis on
a fait le tour de cette vidéo
j'espère que l vous aura plu j'espère
que vous aurez appris des choses sur le
log
voilà rien de très très compliqué on est
resté sur quand même quelque chose
d'assez simple et encore une fois je le
répète je ne suis pas est à l'honneur
donc là dessus il ya certainement plein
de choses à redire n'empêche que le
résultat est pas d'exode et puis comme
d'habitude si cette vidéo vous a plu si
vous en voulez d'autres si vous aimez
chronique fiction vous mettez un coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo ça
fait toujours plaisir que vous abonner
si c'est pas déjà fait dans les
commentaires pouvez me dire ce que vous
avez pensé de cette vidéo ce que vous
avez pensé de la colo si vous aimez vous
aussi chronique fiction si vous êtes un
fan inconditionnel d'un terreau stellar
tout comme moi et de christopher nolan
par conséquent et donc de stéphane godin
aussi peuvent mettre tout ça dans les
commentaires
et puis moi je vous dis comme d'habitude
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo tu vois c'était pas
compliqué en vrai les gens restez chez
vous car sur vous prenez soin de vous
prenez soin de votre entourage
c'est chaud en ce moment
on essaie de changer les idées et tout
ça mais voilà je suis de tout coeur avec
vous dans cette épreuve là et merci
d'être là et voilà fait des vidéos chez
vous faites des petites du petit birol
l'intérieur je pense qu'on fera une
vidéo paroles d'intérieur
pendant ce tout ça là et voilà soyez
prudent fait attention et